FEELINGS, AND ALSO DAVE CULLEN,
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING WITH
US.
>>> NOW THE UNITED KINGDOM FELL
SILENT AT NOON TODAY, REFLECTING
ON THE 126,000 LIVES LOST TO
COVID ON THE ANNIVERSARY OF THIS
COUNTRY'S FIRST LOCKDOWN.
IT HAS BEEN A DEVASTATING TOLL.
BUT HERE, TOO, A NATIONAL
EPIDEMIC OF VIOLENCE AGAINST
WOMEN IS TAKING CENTER STAGE.
IT IS A CONVERSATION MOST
RECENTLY TRIGGERED BY THE
KILLING OF SARAH EVERARD RIGHT
HERE IN LONDON EARLIER THIS
MONTH.
JOINING ME TO TALK ABOUT ALL OF
THIS IS THE BRITISH LAWMAKER
JESS PHILLIPS.
HER BRIEF IS DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
AND PROTECTING WOMEN AS SHADOW
MINISTER FOR THE OPPOSITION
LABOR PARTY.
JESS PHILLIPS, WELCOME TO THE
PROGRAM.
I JUST WONDER, YOU'RE OBVIOUSLY
DEALING WITH THE VIOLENCE
PARTICULARLY AGAINST WOMEN HERE
AND THE SURGE IN DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE UNDER THE LOCKDOWN,
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THE
UNRESTRICTED AND UN-TRAMMELLED
USE OF GUNS AND THE MASS MURDER
THAT KEEPS PUNCTUATING AMERICAN
LIFE WITH SUCH REGULARITY?
>> I MEAN, IT IS BEWILDERING I
THINK TO EUROPEAN LAWMAKERS AND
CERTAINLY BRITISH LAWMAKERS LIKE
MYSELF, THAT IT SEEMS SO OBVIOUS
THE SOLUTION, WHICH WILL TAKE A
LONG TIME I THINK IN THE U.S. TO
TAKE HOLD AFTER SENSIBLE LAWS
COULD BE PUT IN PLACE AROUND GUN
CONTROL AND CHECKS AND BALANCES
IN THE SYSTEM THAT EXIST HERE.
THE IDEA HERE THAT MY SONS COULD
JUST GO OUT AS SOME SORT OF
RETALIATION AND GO AND BUY A GUN
DOWN THE ROAD IS IT'S A
PHENOMENON TO BRITISH PEOPLE
THAT THAT IS THE SYSTEM IN MANY
STATES OF AMERICA.
AND IT JUST SEEMS -- WHAT SEEMS
SO UNFATHOMABLE TO ME AS
SOMEBODY WHO HAS DEDICATED MY
LIFE TO POLITICAL SERVICE
BECAUSE OF VIOLENCE.
WHY AREN'T OBVIOUS SOLUTIONS
CONSIDERED?
I WAS 18 YEARS OLD AND AT SCHOOL
WHEN THE COLUMBINE INCIDENT
OCCURRED.
AND HEARING THAT FATHER JUST
BEFORE, I CANNOT BELIEVE THAT
PROGRESS HAS NOT BEEN MADE.
WHEN IN THE UK ONE SINGLE MURDER
IN THE LAST TWO WEEKS HAS FORCED
POLITICAL CHANGE ALREADY.
>> I AM GOING TO TALK ABOUT
THAT, BUT I THINK IT'S WORTH
REMEMBERING THAT A MASS MURDER
HERE IN THE UK WAS IN SCOTLAND,
MADE IT IMPOSSIBLE TO BUY THOSE
KINDS OF WEAPONS.
AND THERE WAS SERIOUS GUN
LEGISLATION IN AUSTRALIA AROUND
THE SAME YEAR THE SAME HAPPENED.
AND MOST RECENTLY IN NEW ZEALAND
AFTER THE CHRISTCHURCH MASSACRE.
WITHIN SIX DAYS THERE WAS GUN
LEGISLATION AND RESTRICTIONS
THAT THE PEOPLE WHO, YOU KNOW,
VOTED AND AGREED WITH.
CAN I ASK YOU ABOUT YOUR OWN
BRIEF AS WELL?
BECAUSE, AS I SAID, YOU ARE THE
SHADOW MINISTER RESPONSIBLE FOR
WOMEN'S SAFETY, AND YOU'VE BEEN
VERY VOCAL SINCE SARAH EVERARD.
AND YOU ALWAYS ARE ABOUT THIS
ISSUE.
AGAIN, SARAH EVERARD, YOU KNOW,
COLORADO, IT'S ALL COMING AT THE
SAME TIME AS WHAT HAPPENED IN
ATLANTA WHERE WOMEN WERE
TARGETED AND KILLED AS WELL.
WHAT IS IT WITH THE STATS ON
GENDER-BASED VIOLENCE AND
KILLING THAT IS SO OUT OF WHACK?
>> I MEAN, THE REALITY IS THAT
WE DON'T, AS POLICYMAKERS
GLOBALLY ACTUALLY TRACK IT
PROPERLY.
THE SARAH EVERARD MURDER HAS
SHAKEN EVERYBODY ACROSS THE
UNITED KINGDOM, MEN, WOMEN,
POLICYMAKERS ALIKE HAVE BEEN
SHOCKED BY THAT.
BUT THE REALITY IS THAT IN THE
WEEK THAT SARAH EVERARD WAS
MISSING BEFORE HER BODY WAS
FOUND AND SOMEBODY WAS CHARGED
WITH HER KILLING, IN THAT WEEK,
SIX WOMEN IN THE UNITED KINGDOM
WERE KILLED IN THEIR HOME AND A
LITTLE GIRL.
SO, THE INCIDENTS OF THIS CASE
COMPARED WITH THE HUGE NUMBERS
OF DATA IN THE UNITED KINGDOM
EVERY THREE DAYS A WOMAN IS
MURDERED AT THE HANDS OF A MAN
USUALLY, OF A PARTNER OR
EX-PARTNER.
IF YOU SCALE THAT UP, IF WE LOOK
AT TERRORIST INCIDENCES,
DOMESTIC AND INTERNATIONAL
TERRORIST INCIDENCES IN THE UK,
IN AUSTRALIA, AROUND THE WORLD,
WE CAN SEE THAT THERE IS OFTEN
PATTERNS IN THOSE WHO PERPETRATE
SUCH VIOLENCE OF VIOLENCE
AGAINST WOMEN AND GIRLS.
YET, I'M AFRAID TO SAY THAT
WOMEN'S LIVES ARE STILL
CONSIDERED TO BE LESS IMPORTANT.
SO, WHEN WOMEN ARE DYING, IT'S
VERY RARELY TRACKED AS TO WHY
THAT'S HAPPENING.
IT'S VERY RARELY MONITORED.
IT'S VERY RARELY SEEN AS BEING
PART OF AN OVERALL ISSUE.
IT'S JUST ONE OF THOSE THINGS.
AND THAT HAS BEEN THE CASE IN
THE UNITED KINGDOM FOR A LONG
TIME, THE MURDER IN TURKEY IN
THE LAST FEW WEEKS, WE SEE THE
SAME THING, AND THE SHOOTING IN
ATLANTA RECENTLY.
THE REALITY IS, IS TO NOT SEE
THAT IN TERMS OF BEING VIOLENCE
AGAINST WOMEN AND GIRLS WOULD BE
WRONG.
THAT IS NOT SIMPLY JUST ANOTHER
MASS SHOOTING.
THAT IS A MASS SHOOTING THAT
SPECIFICALLY TARGETED WOMEN
BECAUSE THEY WERE WOMEN.
>> WHAT HAS HAPPENED?
ARE YOU SATISFIED?
YOU SAID, OBVIOUSLY EVERYBODY
WHO'S BEEN SHOCKED BY THE SARAH
EVERARD MURDER, ARE YOU
SATISFIED WITH WHAT THE
GOVERNMENT IS DOING?
WHAT ACTUALLY HAS COME OF THIS
IN TERMS OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
PROTECTION?
>> WELL, IT'S STILL RELATIVELY
EARLY DAYS.
I'M SATISFIED THAT THE
GOVERNMENT HAS RECOGNIZED THAT
THEY'VE GOT TO DO SOMETHING, AND
THAT FEELS LOUD AND CLEAR.
WHAT THEY HAD TO DO HERE, WHICH
IS OFTEN WHAT HAPPENS IN
LEGISLATURE IS THAT QUICKLY
SOMETHING HAS TO BE CAME UP
WITH.
AND WHAT THEY CAME UP WAS A SORT
OF TIRED, OLD IDEAS ABOUT
STREETLIGHTING AND UNDERCOVER
POLICE OFFICERS IN BARS, WHICH
WILL GO ALMOST NOWHERE TO
ADDRESSING THE ISSUE THAT WOMEN
DON'T FEEL SAFE ON THE STREETS
OF THE UNITED KINGDOM.
BUT I THINK THAT THIS AND OFF
THE BACK OF THE COVID-19
PANDEMIC AND THE LOCKDOWN THAT
HAS CAUSED PEOPLE ALL ACROSS THE
WORLD TO HAVE A UNIVERSAL
EXPERIENCE OF BEING FRIGHTENED
AND LOCKED IN THEIR HOMES MEANS
THAT PUBLIC ATTENTION IS ON
VIOLENCE AGAINST WOMEN AND GIRLS
IN A WAY THAT IT HASN'T BEEN
BEFORE.
SO THE GOVERNMENT WILL -- YOU
KNOW, THEY WON'T IGNORE IT.
BUT, YET, NO DIRECT SPECIFIC
ACTION HAS BEEN TAKEN.
WHICH IS ALARMING MANY, MANY
WOMEN IN THIS COUNTRY.
WE SEE TWITTER FEEDS.
WE SEE THE ACTIVIST GROUPS
REALLY TRYING TO PRESS THIS
POINT HOME.
AND ABOUT THE POLICE, YOU SAID,
YOU KNOW, SORT OF MILK TOAST
SOLUTIONS TO MORE LIGHTING AND
MORE PATROLS AND UNDERCOVER COPS
IN BARS.
BUT IT IS A POLICEMAN WHO'S BEEN
ARRESTED FOR THE KILLING OF
SARAH EVERARD.
AND I THINK PEOPLE ACROSS THIS
COUNTRY AND AROUND THE WORLD
WERE PRETTY SHOCKED WHEN POLICE
WERE MANHANDLING WOMEN WHO
TURNED UP AT A VIGIL FOR SARAH
EVERARD TO REMEMBER HER AND LAY
FLOWERS.
AND PEOPLE WERE VERY UPSET.
THE VERY INSTITUTION THAT'S
MEANT TO PROTECT THESE WOMEN ARE
ACTUALLY VISIBLY, IN THIS CASE,
NOT.
WHAT HAS TO HAPPEN TO MAKE THAT
CHANGE?
>> I MEAN, LAW ENFORCEMENT IN
THIS COUNTRY ACTUALLY, THE VERY
VISCERAL IMAGES THAT WE SAW OF
POLICE OFFICERS PINNING DOWN
WOMEN AT A VIGIL IN MEMORY OF
SARAH EVERARD, A VIGIL THAT THE
FUTURE QUEEN OF OUR COUNTRY HAD
ATTENDED EARLIER THAT DAY TO
GIVE AN IDEA OF SORT OF THE
SENSE OF NATIONAL MOURNING
AROUND THIS ISSUE, TO THEN SEE
THAT TURN TO SOMETHING THAT
APPEARED AS THE POLICE ACTING IN
A VERY HEAVY-HANDED AND
UNNECESSARY FASHION.
THAT IS THE TIP OF THE ICEBERG,
I WOULD SAY, WITH REGARDS TO HOW
WOMEN IN THE UNITED KINGDOM AND
AROUND THE WORLD FEEL ABOUT
WHETHER THEY WILL BE TRYSTED BY
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
WHAT HAS TO BE DONE IS A HUGE
PIECE OF WORK WITH ALL ELEMENTS,
THE COURTS AND POLICE SERVICES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY THAT REALLY
PUSHES THE IDEA THAT IF WOMEN
COME FORWARD AND SAY THAT
THEY'VE BEEN FOLLOWED, IF WOMEN
THEY'VE BEEN RAPED.
IF WOMEN COME FORWARD AND
EXPRESS HOW THEY'RE BEING ABUSED
IN THEIR HOMES, THE PROPER AND
APPROPRIATE ACTION WILL ALWAYS
BE TAKEN.
BECAUSE I'M AFRAID TO SAY THAT
THE VAST MAJORITY OF CASES OF
RAPE, FOR EXAMPLE, IN THIS
COUNTRY, ARE STILL EITHER ONLY
ONE IN SIX WOMEN WILL EVER
REPORT, MEANING THAT FIVE OUT OF
SIX WOMEN JUST SIMPLY DON'T
TRUST THAT THEY WILL BE LISTENED
TO.
BUT OF THE ONE IN SIX THAT DO
COME FORWARD, WE SEE A TINY
FRACTION, LESS THAN 5% EVER
SEEING THE INSIDE OF A COURTROOM
AROUND THEIR CASE.
THEIR CASE IS, BY AND LARGE,
BEING DROPPED.
SO THAT IS THE ISSUE THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN THIS COUNTRY HAS
TO GET OVER.
IT HAS TO GET OVER A FUNDAMENTAL
TRUST ISSUE.
AND IT CERTAINLY HASN'T HELPED
WITH IMAGES AROUND THE COUNTRY